so the general question is how come that
we are now live in time and what they
call populism or whatever you want to
call it and more and more offer to of
eclectic regimes why is that now to
quote more or less becoming the new rule
instead of you know old-fashioned
liberal democracy based on liberal
values I think I would want to ask the
question whether whether we may be in
the submerge sense but nonetheless in a
real sense many people certainly many
people in the West and the other parts
of the world whether not whether we
accept right now the whole package
called liberal democracy but do we
accept core moral principles on which
the liberal democracy is built and core
more principles in which it is built or
- that is one is the freedom of
conscience and that and the other one is
equal dignity of every every person an
equal voice in running the public
affairs and it would seem to me that
although it seems that we are in the
process of untied democratization so to
speak in the world today nonetheless for
many people these two core or three core
principles they remain stable and I
think I would want to build upon these
principles and strengthen so that we can
build the kind of institutions that are
appropriate to local situations but that
embody these two principles will have
plurality then will have the ability to
live together as different let me say
something the way I see it
no Russia is not a liberal democracy and
though it has certain people certainly I
would say virtual community of those who
say that they share these liberal
democratic principles but actually they
do not because they have their own
little dictatorship and you cannot trust
them in no way now what happens Russia
is an autocratic state it always has
been
always it was never interrupted by any
democracy at all so you have to take
that into consideration talking about
this country it's the same thing
with many middle eastern countries
governments they are based on different
principles which Americans who enter the
country did not understand they may have
been in a horrible in many ways but you
should not break these principles or
suggest some Western approach you know
to Iraq or whatever otherwise you get
what you get now about inertia the way
there are people in Russia who not being
Christians no but having this really
loving hearts understand that some huge
problems should be dealt with one of
them is no doctors and no hospitals for
children with oncology right so in order
to build these hospitals out of nowhere
the government doesn't want to listen
about it doesn't want to hear there was
a woman and actors Jill pancha whatever
is her name she couldn't stand it she
couldn't see it she had some money of
her own and she was very loved by people
she's a good actress and a very nice
person she she started this program
trying to make the government built this
huge hospital for children with an
collage occur diseases and in order to
get some money to fundraise she went as
far as to meet Putin and he was because
no one wanted actually to say yes
finally here's my signature all money
that was promised was somewhere
disappeared quickly
there were many marathons fundraising
marathons but money did disappear so she
needed support a real solid support so
she went as far as the mid Putin and he
helped her so the hospital with all
doctors everything was built now
this liberal public started hating
children they hated her so much they
just shamed her they said all kinds of
dirty things about her because she did
you know to contact Putin and put in his
bed and put in as a dictator so to hell
with your you know ill children the
moral principles are much more important
for them this is one extreme case and
another one is right now these days
yesterday I read more news about it
there is another woman on the feather
Messer she and her mother her late
mother were the founders of the hospices
for terminally ill for people who are
terminally ill because these people they
didn't get any relief they couldn't get
painkillers nothing like that they just
stayed in their apartments in horrible
pain they did a great work and they
built hospitals all around the cities
and they saved the this pain and there
is lost
you know sufferings for many people and
also she went as high as far as first
the mayor of Moscow whom everyone hates
for many reasons and then up to Putin so
the last I saw yesterday was her photo
she and Putin they stood in front of
each other and discussing things when
they see these photos I know that the
people who and it may be me tomorrow you
know who will suffer from this in
cruciate in pain with no way out because
the only way out is dying you know she's
she's saving their people you cannot
imagine the wave of hatred that this
liberal public you know had pushed
against her it's like a tsunami so to
hell with these people who
have moral principles I prefer staying
with those who have this heart you know
going to children and old people they
gain nothing tiny bit but to say the
same footin has also been responsible
for extraordinary cruelty yes you're
giving instances of benevolent that's
right no yeah I know the thing is that
this this cruelty would have happened
anyway sure sure this is my idea that's
how this type of countries are how they
run Russian lacks is historical
perspective and in liberal democracy is
what a hundred one hundred fifty years
old probably not two hundred years old
and it is a kind of miracle that it ever
came into existence and no wait wait but
one of the things you learn about all
forms of progress is that progress is
never linear and it's never inevitable
and it's never irreversible so that the
struggle it's there will never come a
time when the whole world will be once
and for all Liberal Democratic it's like
the beginning of that film mr.
incredible when they're interviewing and
they say to him aren't you tired of
rescuing people and he says yeah I saved
the world but the world just won't stay
saved I mean you know those those
principles of which I spoke earlier are
centuries old they have to take
political form because they have to have
something to do with how political power
relates to them right but my point is
you're absolutely right my point is
Russia is not a liberal democracy it's
very very far from it why doesn't it you
know try to pick up this you know to
have America as a model for different
reasons but while it doesn't happen
those who the the public you know the
community which could have been a
community of people who would somehow
help transfer the principles of liberal
democracy to Russia they spent their
time on hatred and hatred towards
those who are doing something not being
Christians in both cases so do you think
that democracy is not a universal
concept this is what people say about
Muslim societies that they just not I
think I am Not sure but I think that
Russia is a hybrid society in this
respect because the idea of democracy is
not completely rejected you know in
Russia the the society is loose in this
way in many ways religiously loose in
many other ways and it is rather good if
Russia became a liberal democracy it
will not it will not know I'm a liberal
democracy no I don't know but when they
were efforts of establishing democracy
in early 90s then people chose for
example the governors of the city the
mayors from the bandits because these
bandits they already stole killed enough
people and stole enough money to give
people promises and people are promised
okay this is how democracy work they
were very democratic it was very
democratic procedures and so it happened
once and then the second time the third
time and of course when you see it and
you think ok that these people they are
really crazy and it will lose everything
and these people will stop let's just go
around these principles so you start
going around these principles and you
end up with autocracy
you